وثائق سريه لا لا ليست سريه ان كانت سريه
او غير ذلك كيف يمكن ان ينتهي الامر بتلك
الوثائق الحساسه في غير محلها وكيف يتم
التخلص منها عند كل صباح يتم اعداد ملخص
يومي استخباراتيه لشاغل المكتب البيضاوي
المواد الاكثر سريه وحساسيه عاده ما يتم
اعدادها خارج البيت الابيض داخل الوكالات
الاستخباراتيه المتخصصه
باستخدام طابعه خاصه متصله بنظام البريد
الالكتروني المصنف
يقوم الافراد العاملون هناك بطباعه
المستندات وتجميعها في ملف خاص
بمجرد ان يصبح الملف جاهزا يستلمه الشخص
الموكل اليه ايصاله الى البيت الابيض ثم
يتم وضع الملف في حقيبه مغلقه جيدا
فيما يسجل المسؤولون في المكتب بيانات تلك
الوثيقه المستلمه من استلمها وفي اي وقت
غادر والجهه المرسله اليها الوثيقه بعد
الانتهاء من تلك العمليه واصال الحقيبه من
المفترض ان تتم اعاده تلك الوثيقه الى
مكانها مره اخرى
حيث سيتم تسجيل عودتها وفي معظم الحالات
تحرق تلك المستندات او تتم تلك العمليه
لاحقا
ومع ذلك في بعض الحالات يختار الشخص
المسؤول الاحتفاظ بالوثائق لايام او حتى
اسابيع
عمليه معقده يتم بها نقل الوثائق السريه
وارجاعها ومن ثم التخلص منها الا ان
وثائقي فلتت من قبضه تلك العمليه
الامر الذي اوقع الرئيسيين بيض وترامب في
فخها فخ الوثائق السريه